no magnus carlsen strives from these
matches against the top players here we
go yeah it's the reti opening white
bringing the night out on the first move
and one of my favorites just a calm
quiet opening pushing this white pawn
forward creating a nice home for the
white light squared bishop
black here has a huge amount of choice
what will ding play ding can bring one
of the black knights out occupy the
center with some pawns
plenty of choice what do you think of
this opening uh decision simon
yeah pretty solid i i think it's to to
be expected really from magnus uh as you
said really david i don't think he wants
to take too many risks he does really
respect uh ding as well so he's not
gonna play something completely crazy uh
in this first game uh maybe we'll see
that later on if he's able to get a
victory here
on the other hand we see ding playing
very solid setup
kind of like a french defense really
and magnus now must decide which which
pawn he pushes and then we go
he now pushes the d pawn going into uh
well this this structure i've actually
had with the black pieces many a time um
where you give away the center um but
you can try to attack it from the side
but like the grunt field you play uh i
guess yeah yeah
i agree i was a little bit disappointed
that he picked up the d pawn and pushed
it two squares i was really hoping to
see him push this pawn the deep on one
square and uh get a little bit more of
uh
thematic position here it's uh it's in
the realms of big theory and also you
know it's it's actually something that
both players are very very familiar with
this grim file structure
and
well white has uh one move more than
they usually get because the brimfield
opening is an opening for the black side
yeah so if we do jump in to explain uh
we're talking about openings here white
setup especially with the bishop on this
long diagonal and staring down towards
the black pawn center but along pretty
much the perfect diagonal as well as
black
black here white normally castling the
king this is what we regard as the
grenfeld it's when you allow your
opponent to have the pawn center here
magnus is allowing these very very
strong pawns but white is going to try
and chip away at the center
with his own pawns or with his pieces
and danger says okay he brings the
bishop out normally in the grindfeld we
have colours reversed so as ivanka
mentioned black would normally have his
night out on this square so it's very
similar but of improved version here for
magnus and instead of maybe the most
common move bringing the white bishop
out for example trying to undermine one
of the defenders of black's pawn center
and trying to trade off this night
magnus has pushed his pawn forward and
this is really really ambitious for
carlson firstly he's threatening this
pawn but for example if this pawn is
defended by the black knight
then white might even consider pushing
forward kicking away this bishop driving
it away and once the bishop moves then a
pawn in the center will fall so serious
pressure in the current position on not
only this pawn but this pawn both of
black central pawns under fire at the
moment and black can deal with this in a
couple of ways i think the most natural
the most simple way is to actually just
trade off and capture this white pawn
yes you part with your beautiful center
there with black but at least now you're
compensated for example if white takes
back your isolated pawn in the center of
the board is compensated for by the fact
that white also has an isolated pawn and
here black can simply castle the king
i'm wondering if magnus is actually
going to play something even more
ambitious in this position and take with
his own pawn throwing his pawn up the
board to try and create an attack and at
least undermine the black pieces
yeah it's really
getting spicy already at this early
stage ding seems to be surprised i'm not
sure whether he's seen this position
before
i've looked at it very briefly myself
but it is quite rare uh quite a rare
setup for white and in the current
position this is the decision he has to
make what does he do with the central
pawn you could make an argument for
pushing it forward gaining a bit of
space but if you do this then white
gains squares in the center white now
gets a nice post for his knight white
still has the option of pushing forward
hitting this black bishop it's very very
tense but it's all about these two pawns
in the middle of the board right now and
ding has to do something about them he
has to make a big decision right now
yeah i can just looking at the stats on
my database i can see maybe 2013 or
something this line was popular but
there's somehow it kind of
the fashion died out you know and
suddenly no one started no one was
playing it anymore but it has been
played before and
the main move is actually to play pawn
takes pawn as you suggested and in fact
white's most popular response to that is
actually to capture the pawn back with
another pawn so fireworks on the board
already
yeah you mentioned 2013 i think the last
time i looked at this position was
nearly that far back it was many many
years ago um so maybe magnus he's
actually gained a minute on the clock
since we started the game maybe he's
more
uh familiar with this position than ding
ding now investing quite a long time he
does go for the most popular move and
magnus instantly i think magnus had
pre-moved to recapture a pawn and the
moves are flying down onto the board
white's knight in the middle of the uh
in the middle now
nice square but he gets the bishop he
trades off and now black's pawns in the
center of the board
it's kind of one disappeared and now
it's been replaced by another one but
they are vulnerable on the light squares
white has a light square bishop and can
start
going for some of those black central
pawns first magnus tucks his king
nicely into the corner to a very safe
square
i'm not sure who i prefer here to be
honest white's king potentially
vulnerable but black has a nice pawn
center how about the black king willow
castle
decision time now for ding he can maybe
the most logical move is to just castle
the black king but another option for
ding would be to move the black queen
out of the way and the black king can
actually go on to the other side so
which way is black's king going
difficult uh difficult choice and say if
you were unfamiliar with this particular
opening you've stumbled up into it and
you have to take a choice
where are you going to put the king
uh i am uh yeah i'm part of the chicken
chess club as they say so i think the
black king is going to castle on the
king's side nice and
i mean nice and typical
why is it sort of more dangerous to
castle on different sides
so maybe if we pull up the board we can
demonstrate this so for example here if
black castle's on the same side of the
board because both of the kings are on
the same flank it means it's harder to
throw pawns up the board for example if
white wants to attack the black king now
if white for example throws harry the h
pawn on the board a very typical idea to
go and trade off and open up the black
king then suddenly the white king also
becomes open for example the black
knight could move in and start going for
the white king however um for example
the other way around if black say takes
a timeout okay he moves his king
whatever
he hasn't even castle just to show the
point though just to finish the point
here if the black queen moves for
example white just plays slowly if the
black king goes on the other flank then
black is happy to push pawns towards the
white king because his king is nice and
safe on the other flank he doesn't need
to worry about his own king safety you
can kind of have tunnel vision just
focus on one flank of the board so black
will play on this side white will play
on the other side of the board so it's
kind of just opposite attacks one side
playing on the right wing one side
playing on the left wing
but ding's move we got to explain it
because
this move it looks so weird
not castling the king i guess his idea
is that he actually wants to use his
king as a defender of this uh of this
pawn for example if he had castled maybe
he thinks he would have lost time if
white's bishop comes to the edge of the
board he would need to now defend um
this pawn
but
simon what do you think i mean you're
really sensitive to the weaknesses of
the opponent's king sorry and
this black king it is on an open line oh
well semi-open line
yeah i mean um i i i don't i don't know
why more people don't play this f4 move
uh because i played the setup that ding
has played here quite often as black and
black normally gets a very nice space
advantage and the move that magnus
played uh you noted it was popular maybe
10 years ago so i was sort of looking at
it and thinking yeah that's that's a
good move you know and this is the kind
of thing that magnus does even in these
lines which are not
necessarily that theoretical meaning
there's lot not a lot of information on
he he's very good at finding
ideas and bringing them back to life so
it's like a researcher an academic
researcher you know goes through all
these papers all these books and he's
able to find some obscure idea and and
just give life to it and looking at this
position here i really like white's
position i mean i can see him pushing a
pawn in the middle uh two squares here
um because you've got a light square
bishop as white black doesn't have a
light square bishop so you've got to
think how can i maximize that idea and
you want to open up the bishop so
pushing this pawn two squares i know
disallows an exchange of queens but i
don't see any obvious way to attack the
black king yet uh but this seems like it
it should be a nice small advantage to
white just because that bishop um okay i
mean there are you know it's not perfect
for white but it certainly seems better
uh to white for me yeah at the moment
certainly i completely agree and i love
your move i mean i think it's such an
instructive idea as well you know you
lengthen the scope of your bishop
especially the one that is unchallenged
um didn't you have a rule david about uh
playing
with bishops and and uh just how to
block them with pawns yeah so i guess uh
because black doesn't have a light
squared bishop he okay simon's move on
the board because black doesn't have a
light square bishop it actually makes
sense for black to put his pawns on
light squares to at least grip uh at
least control some of that color complex
but uh magnus now he's trying to erode
uh these strongholds he's trying to
break down these pawns and as simon
mentioned this pawn pushes forward so
just to finish the point of a trade here
white can allow the trade of queens the
queen's staring down at each other or
white could maybe move um the queen out
of the way if you want to keep queens on
the board you can maybe just shift the
queen not sure exactly where uh for
example here yes the knight can jump in
it might be a bit annoying but you could
make an argument for the queens staying
on the board potentially but let's
assume that magnus plays the most
obvious move after this capture and he
just trades in the center and for
example if we do see everything come off
the board this is uh i think a great
illustration of simon's point this white
bishop now is just a phenomenal piece
even if all the rooks come off deep into
the end game this white bishop is going
to control
this side of the board this side of the
board black's knight here is a bit stuck
it has to just block the bishop it's not
competing for the light squares at all
um so we talk about the bishop as the
bishop pair as well white has the two
bishops open position white has the
advantage in this end game remember end
games favor magnus as well in this
matchup so that's why ding i think is
hesitant to trade pawns in the center
because queens might come off and this
white bishop is going to really dominate
the board um so difficult decision for
ding right now do you think he's
actually thinking okay i'm playing
magnus i want to keep the queens on
that's what i would be thinking as well
it's just difficult to do that i can't
really see an alternative to capturing
this pawn
simon this one looks too risky right
pushing forward in the center for black
i mean you've got to think who's king is
safer and even if you're scared of going
into an ending because you're playing uh
the guy who always beats you in endings
and beats everyone in endings you've got
to try to play the best move and i think
that's what ding's done because just
compare the kings white's king is a lot
safer than black's king and i think just
for that reason alone you should get the
most dangerous pieces off the board
and aim for an exchange of queens which
i i i mean if he doesn't exchange queens
it's going to get really dangerous
there's some breaks coming up with the
uh f pawn so i i think he really should
exchange queens shortly yeah so this is
definitely in the uh pushing
pushing this pawn forward breaking
through to the black king so yeah simon
is voting for queen takes queen
capturing the white queen i'm inclined
to agree trade the queens off as i
mentioned white is the one with an
advantage here that's clear black is
just fighting for a draw but at least
you're alive um any other alternatives
other than trading this queen for
example bring the black queen away
somewhere keeping the queens on the
board does allow the white queen to jump
into the attack
and yeah it does look very very scary
pushing this pawn and
clear target for white i'll be
absolutely shocked yeah i mean if ding
does not swap off queens i mean
i mean he wants to live there with the
king in the middle of the board
no one exactly no i mean that king is
just like so naked there i mean it's
really an offense to to the environment
that king you know he's going to get
arrested if he doesn't get the queens
off the board there i mean uh yeah you i
think you have to though i mean just
looks i mean maybe you can survive some
other way but just with the mood david
demonstrated and that
real freeing move uh all the white's
pieces are very nicely positioned for
the attack but i mean not saying that
even if you swap queens off it's it just
looks very nice and white to me
that bishop is so strong white does it
it does doesn't it i mean
this is an ideal position to have right
you're better um you've got a better
position and you haven't really got any
risk um so it's those two result games
you know draw or win you shouldn't lose
this position ever at this level so it's
it's he hasn't done it okay so he's
trying to put some pieces around his
king and it you know it's probably fine
to do this but i would just be scared
you know
you know i'd just be like whoa i'll just
be like my king my poor king eventually
but i mean i'm glad i didn't bet
anything because i was so certain that
the queens would come off that i'd be
like yeah oh another song could be we
have another song i mean we had this
great great tweet yesterday uh of us all
in uh the spice girls band and i think
the only one who looks semi-normal was
you ivanka
i apologize to everyone for putting you
in that situation
but it was
it was at the instigation of simon he
was the cause of this all yeah and uh it
was a long day yesterday you know
can we hear more songs today you know
maybe in the third hour or something
yeah okay well we've got to have it all
or something yeah we want voting to come
in what do we want your vancouver to
sing today well and um
okay when you were it was very nice the
spice girls but
simon and david didn't join in
they were very disappointed
let's do a boy band thing with you guys
today i'm not a boyfriend surely
you get them doing something really
cheesy like backstreet boys yeah yeah i
do i wanted that dress in white suits
and then you can this sounds like a
nightmare
we have done some karaoke together we
have i actually remember down the
karaoke bar uh david the backstreet boys
was a song that did come out for you
occasionally wasn't it so no comment
stay tuned for the singing as long as it
is from the 90s i think david can do it
yes yes i literally don't know any songs
from the 2010s
okay meanwhile no queen trade simon yeah
i mean i'm happy to see this because i i
do like seeing the queens on the ball
but risky yeah risky and the computer
agrees with you 100 there because as
soon as ding avoided the queen trade the
evaluation bar swung the whole way over
for magnus
so white now uh in charge it's all about
the white queen and she does enter the
fray it's not clear exactly what she's
doing yet but she's lining up against
the black king was that the right
direction but also i mean you could have
tried this f5 movement that would be wow
that would have been the first move i'd
have looked at i mean it might not work
but um you certainly it's very very uh
in this position you know a very
thematic idea to blast it open which
david may be showing the analysis board
now and it might involve a peace
sacrifice but look at the black king i
don't care push that pawn because i need
to get rid of the defense around black's
king and
whichever way black takes maybe i can
sacrifice peace there and uh this looks
like a lot of fun it was another idea
yeah i know simon i took a peek at the
computer here and
guess what your move pretty much wins on
the spot here for magnus carlsen blowing
open the position hang up there
hang on a minute just let me let so i i
play better than magnus
one time in my life
at least one move yeah one move i did
one move very nice but you're right the
idea has been in the air for a long time
the idea is still in the air now and he
missed the one moment the one
opportunity to kind of throw this pawn
forward and just to show if the pawn
recaptures then suddenly this diagonal
is open towards the black king this is
deadly uh if the other black pawn
captures then this diagonal is open
towards the black king also deadly so
magnus missing this opportunity some
calculation needs to be done of course
as simon mentioned you need to work out
that you can maybe for example sacrifice
a piece blow open even more lines
towards the black king
but i think magnus should have invested
a little bit more time he barely paused
at all he played the queen move
instantly and uh ignoring this pawn push
might well have been a huge opportunity
missed so white's queen came out in the
end and now look at what ding has done
he's so terrified of this pawn push that
he's using the black knight to come over
and defend and i think this is a great
idea from ding um over the last couple
of turns
and uh yeah now if we fast forward to
the current position
white has actually won a pawn um sorry
actually to rewind that white is
actually one of pawn this pawn very
valuable one but after the bishop
captured black's rook moved and now
black's knight at least occupies and
blockades the pawn push so black's
actually given up a pawn just to stop
simon's idea that's how big that's how
scary it was why did magnus spend a
whole move on just moving his rook
one square behind another pawn yeah here
i guess this pawn is under fire and your
bishop is stuck at home unable to
develop if it has to stay at home and
defend this pawn so by moving his rook
across
now he has freed up his bishop and as we
saw in the last turn he's moved it away
so he's replaced one passive piece the
bishop which is now active with another
passive piece now he has the problem of
how to activate his rook just defending
this pawn
yeah suddenly i quite like ding's
position yes blacks are pawn down but
look at black's pieces uh the black
rooks both on great lines this line and
this line and black's knight doing a
great job of blockading if white ever
takes off this knight from the board um
over the next few moves then for example
here
black is very very safe the king has a
nice
square to kind of tuck itself away too
so do you think magnus will be sort of
annoyed after the game when he checks it
and realizes he had a huge opportunity
it depends on what the result is of
course if the result is a draw then
he'll look back on this and think okay
this is a missed opportunity
if it's a loss then okay he'll be
kicking himself excessively and uh if he
wins he'll be like uh
oh well look at that i missed the win i
think it's not even about the fact he
didn't play it i mean even if he'd seen
it he might not end up playing it he
might have calculated but just he just i
mean he missed the moment completely he
just developed his queen without
thinking
if he'd invested two minutes for example
he has 13 and a half if he invested two
minutes i think he would have realized
that just like simon that it was
incredibly strong and the black king
would barely survive
and uh okay meanwhile ding has pushed
this pawn forward the reason i showed
this on the
analysis board a few moments ago is
because black's pawn
it is a lone ranger right now that black
pawn is fighting against three white
pawns but it can destabilize white
structure it's going to act as a
as a battery battering ram and minority
attack that's what we call it one pawn
destabilizing three white's pawns over
on that left side they can't move
they're a bit stuck
so uh white with the advantage simon but
it's difficult now
yeah i mean i i'm not even sure which
side i'd rather be now i mean you do
have the extra pawn um obviously that's
good but
i mean this knight maneuver that ding
played was a really really clever idea
because it just stops uh all the
problems that you had around your king
and you know when you lose a pawn you
get more open lines and uh ding loves
having activity this is where he he
really thrives in positions where he has
open lines open diagonals and he's got
that now so i i think ding will be a lot
happier at least than then he was uh you
know let's say five ten moves ago and i
don't know you've anchored you're a pawn
grabber uh so are you david aren't you
ready i mean you're both in the pawn
grabbing camp but would you would you
prefer to be white in this
position yeah slightly but that was a
really that was a real
it was i was not sure you see because
you know any time that what tries to do
something in the position there's going
to be consequences like for instance
white's king not great in the corner
it's got a lot of air around it and uh
take a look at black's rooks on the open
line you can't challenge them at all
so
i just i think that magnus now needs to
start to regroup a little bit
and
just
find a way to
do something but it's not easy yeah yeah
i don't know what the right plan is
david here for white i mean it's it's uh
okay he's putting his pieces on safer
squares i guess you want to exchange off
on the d file i mean uh get to an ending
this would be ideal for magnus if you
could get rid of all the heavy pieces
maybe uh you can then try to use your
pawn advantage but you you're quite a
long way from that here yeah you're
quite a long way and it's all about
timing i'm slightly surprised the black
rook didn't kind of jump into the second
rank it has an entry square here and if
the black rook would come in it does
kind of stare at some white pawns maybe
magnus was aiming to meet this by
offering a trade of rooks challenging uh
trading things off here but instead of
this ding has met a retreating move this
is good strategy if your opponent
retreats like white did with his bishop
then you should step forward and black's
queen has jumped in and remember this
guy alice the a pawn here uh under fire
now it's not easy to protect her if the
white pawn steps forward then suddenly
um you lose all the integrity of these
pawns for example at some point if black
pushes this pawn forward it locks down
and white's pawns now are completely
immobilized
on this side so that's when white's
majority lies you don't want a structure
like that where you can never push the
pawns
so in the current position if magnus
can't really push this pawn or doesn't
want to then
how do you defend it for example if you
push this pawn away to kick the queen
then the queen can i think safely regain
a pawn this queen is now defended by its
bishop so black regains the pawn black
is doing at least fine
really interesting position here as
simon said if white gets a couple of
moves to bring the rook across and trade
things off then white's doing well but
you just don't have the luxury for
example if the rook comes across now
black will just take and uh your queen
cannot recapture the queen is tied down
to this bishop so white's rook has to
take back and then i think blackstrap
can just jump in
looking great i mean these pieces
coordinate so well for black black's
king is really safe for example there
might even be one check but the black
king can move away now or the black
pieces can just block and uh it's
actually blacks rook and queen that are
getting into the white camp more than uh
the other way around so
it might be interesting to bring up
stockfish here because i was just
wondering what does white play here
because you know if i put myself in
white's position
and um okay so
uh i think i would give back the pawn
yeah there's too much tension in the
position and that's what the computer's
suggesting oh really
to give back to paul these three moves
though the top three suggestions from
stockfish i don't think magnus is going
to play any of those yeah they're just
not natural so the top suggestion is
moving the white queen back to this
square okay keeping the white king nice
and safe but what does it actually do
yeah not really not too much they're all
nothing moves and you know imagine
you're white in this position and
david's pointed out why you can't touch
the pawns on the queen side um but he
has he's touched pawn and queen side
he's given a pawn back now in order i
think to get rid of the queens i think
he was just too square as squared
squares
two squared a new phrase i'm too squared
do you have like a square meaning nerdy
you do yeah i'm very squared in this
position uh he was too squared and and
he wanted to get rid of the queens which
uh um which means it should be fine now
at least for black i i thought okay the
queens have just left the board and in
this current position i think black is
uh as you mentioned there uh simon
completely fine because the black knight
is so rock solid so strong the only
thing you have to be careful of is the
white rook kind of entering the black
camp so
why not challenge the white rook offer a
trade or at least just move your
blackrook up one square and cover any
entry points
it's looking very very balanced but it's
the end game and that suits magnus
carlsen and we did see the bar also to
the middle looking balanced in game one
between anishigiri and pragnanda as well
anish has the white pieces in the first
game and we will of course follow the
action in that semi-final as well uh it
looks like anisha is trying to bore
prank to death in that game
poor prague it's one of the most dull
positions i've ever seen
wow that is a real that's a real harsh
word there david sorry and he's quite
glad we chose this game that's what i'm
trying to say and yesterday we were
saying how exciting uh anish was and how
he goes to the wind but
it's not a bad idea to bore the
youngster to death is it either say but
that's what i would do
sometimes that's uh that's the one thing
the young players can't handle meanwhile
surprising decision maybe that ding has
allowed the white rook i said you should
cover its entry point but the white rook
did go up to the seventh rank with the
check the black king moved and white's
rook has gone greedy and grabbed a pawn
so white's gone upon up again
but is the white rook badly placed
that can trade a set of bishops i'm just
really surprised because it feels like
now there's pressure on ding to do
something
i mean there's something there must be
something very good here for black
otherwise you're just pouring down i
mean maybe you can just uh exchange
bishops and bring your rook in that
would be a very logical
way to proceed just get your work to the
seventh franc i mean the black knight is
is is beautiful at the moment
uh so black's pieces do do seem to be
very nicely placed uh so i i mean
bringing the rook down now that that's
the most logical thing attacker pawn but
there's other options as well uh
we're expecting i mean one of the black
crooks to move right black's knight is
too good you don't want to touch it yet
and you'll move there simon
and uh
yeah i think white might just challenge
this rook white's rook there we go it
steps up if your opponent's rook
dominates your second rank or seventh
rank if you're black then you need to
kick those rooks away so white's rook
trying to hold the fort for now but
black's rooks are now teaming up
protecting each other and there's a
threat in the position which is just to
simply
trade off works and then the other rook
will come down to the second row give a
check and uh recover that lost pawn for
example if white plays a very natural
move this rook is not doing much if
white brings his rook the whole way
across again tries to target black's
isolated pawn then ivanka's point is
that black doesn't need to defend it yet
black can counter-attack trade-off
instead of rooks and the other rook
replaces it and now this black group
just conquers the second round
completely
and you grab this one protecting this
pawn in the process and actually here
it's definitely easier for black to play
black's knight has much more mobility
than the white bishop which kind of hits
thin air so
yeah this one looks very good for ding
suddenly so this is the current position
um after black's rook has come across
magnus needs to deal with that threat of
rook takes rook and then as you've
anchor mentioned to bring the other rook
down
to replace it
looks like i mean if anyone's pushing
it's maybe even black here
but i say that there's not many pawns on
the board
and a draw is probably the most likely
result there's a lot of play left of
course firstly yeah so i thought a draw
was probably the most likely but then i
was
quite uncomfortable about the white king
actually white king is going to be cut
off on the first one but anyway this is
the idea behind this one though very
strange move yeah by magnus trading off
rooks now and dink's rook comes in as we
mentioned this was a threat but magnus
didn't guard against the threat it's
level pawns but the black knight is just
a great piece magnus's idea is to just
try and trade off the remaining pawns
and force the draw he's trying to get a
draw isn't he yeah i mean this is magnus
playing playing for a draw by getting
rid of his weak pawns trying to exchange
everything off but he's he's certainly a
little bit worse now with his king cut
off and the black knight being it's just
a better piece it's a bit scary for
example if the black knight comes in it
just has done um attacking the bishop
attacking the pawn magnus now has had to
drop his bishop the whole way back
it's about it's just about holding
together um yes the bishop protects the
pawn but it's very ugly for magnus right
now the king actually on its starting
square the bishop on the back rank as
well let's go back to the players the
pawns are coming off the board however
so magnus is a big favorite to hold this
ding should be the only one who can win
though looks nervous today magnus and a
little bit nervous players i'd say as
well um
he got a great opening in this one uh he
could not have asked for a better
opening very interesting
very quickly
play very quickly he missed some really
strong moves and even after that is a
little bit nervy so it's a it's a bit of
a worrying worrying start for magnus i
think this game maybe magnus saw that
yesterday ding against mahmoud there
were a few moments where ding lost
control because he was so far behind on
the clock maybe magnus thought he can
bully him on time and put pressure
psychologically but yeah this game
things held firm held his own dodgy
opening from ding but ever since that
ding's been great right yeah yeah
yeah it was yeah like you say simon was
perfect opening for magnus but there's
just that one shot
one opportunity sometimes chess is all
about timing and uh i have to say after
that ding's defense was just incredible
very good i think ding understood the
danger uh to it to his king and magnus
didn't which is uh which is just better
awareness from ding at the start of the
game um i mean i do expect this to be a
draw i mean you know there's so little
material on the board but you can see
black's three pieces are combining
together very nicely and if that black
king can get into the position but it
might be a draw here is it gonna be a
draw i think second time we've seen this
position and okay there we go a
repetition of moves it's the draw
surprised a little bit there but anyway